so really good so download and follow us
on the Stardust app in a product
placement video for them just that was
from the app so we're gonna talk about a
quiet place reason to see number uno
directing and sound design never have I
seen a movie I'm sure I have but this is
one of those for you where sound design
is such a crucial element to the film
the way it's all toyed with in this
movie you essentially got three elements
of sound design in this movie the one
very quiet atmosphere in the film when
you're just cutting around to any of the
characters or following any of them and
then you got the Deaf character who is
the daughter the actress is named
Millicent Simmons whenever it cuts to
her you're seeing a scene from her
perspective pretty much no audio or it's
got that humming buzzing kind of sound
whenever you're hearing from a deaf
person's perspective and then the third
element is just all the random sound
design that you hear in the film that
plays into such a factor jump scares are
so earned in this movie it's crazy yeah
and there's a ton of stuff that they do
even between those different modes of
sound to kind of shift and play with it
there are a lot of really clever
flourishes and stuff even just down to
like the sharing of an earbud or
something like that like there's a lot
of creative sound and if you've ever
tried to make a movie like sound is
something people easily overlooking is
one of the most important things and to
see a movie that really thrives based
off really next-level sound design
that's really gratifying this film is
directed by John Krasinski well he has a
confident hand behind that camera man
yeah this is a tense character family
horror mood piece I think it's different
than what some people might be expecting
because it is very character driven and
it really is about its mood and its tone
it's really lived in in yeah so it takes
its time but it doesn't indulge in
taking its time and one thing I
appreciate about this hugely is that
it's a visually told story yeah and the
day and age were like everyone's
creating a universe in a world and
dumping exposition on you it was so
refreshing to watch a story that was
clearly mapped out like they'll have two
or three shots in one fluid camera
motion you're watching the actors really
emot-- you have to have a attention to
all visuals around you reason the scene
number two the cast John Krasinski is
funnier in this than he has ever been
license to Wed has nothing on him
their shots over the top of his desk
while he's going like you know plastic
Jim and Emily Blunt I could see why
she's the next Mary pop you could see
why these guys are married because of
the fun chemistry they just have it
basically romantic ya know this film is
like we keep saying like a family drama
and a character study in its own way
this family that is surviving in this
post-apocalyptic world where a lot of
people are taken out by these creatures
that are blind but can hunt you based
off the sounds you make so in this movie
the characters naturally are people who
will have to do mainly body language
performances like yes you get one
character in here who is just deaf and
she's a really great actress in the film
but the other characters because they
have to be so quiet it's a lot of sign
language a lot of whispering that when
they actually talk in a normal voice
like oh yeah you could yeah it's really
strange one actually utter a word or two
even and you start to realize like even
whispers start to feel odd they feel
like a real family they really give a
weight and a credibility to just the
life that they've drawn with this it's
not a very populated movie even on IMDB
there's something like six people listed
yeah and everybody does a terrific job
again like they they really honed in on
that family vibe and I only drove at
home Jonathas in ski but I loved about
his performance tears I never got the
impression that this dude directed the
movie which can often happen when a guy
directs himself and it's the first role
I've seen of him I didn't see that 13
hours movie where I'm like yeah this
dude's a man really believe him in this
scenario and it was funny because I feel
like a lot people would associate him as
Jim Halpert from the office from a show
that's comedy based and then like such a
serious performance here it actually
makes a lot of sense that he would do
this kind of performance because the
office humor is based off subtlety and
realistic expressions and stuff I'm like
that's what he's doing here just in a
different show
in a more intense role Emily Blunt
fantastic job in this movie - if she
brings a lot of hearts and a lot of the
emotional core - because she is she's
the mother of a mother V yeah yeah and
like she's gotta be just as strong - and
like the scenes were they both in their
own ways like empower their kids in the
face of this horrific situation they're
all trapped
you'd think that they were a real family
and the kid the kids are all really good
- all around they all do this great job
of internalizing a lot and a moding
primarily through body language and
facial expression and lack of dialogue
so kudos with all the actors reason to
see number three the designs the designs
in this movie I did see a headline about
John Krasinski changing the design
creatures and like post or something
like that it's not an all-out creature
feature like no let's get right up in it
like you know really show you how gooey
it all is it's definitely a unique
creature and they established very early
on in the movie that these creatures are
blind they work by hunting people off
here and the sound you get a really good
insight into what they look like yeah I
love the design that they went with I
don't want to say anything about it but
it is a unique and horrifying yeah
especially on the close-ups like a
close-up shots like well it looks really
cool not only next-level effect I would
have would have preferred is if they
were able to do it practical but as it
stands for CGI it looks very realistic
and it looks pretty damn good and they
used it smartly and even beyond that
just the whole movie the world they live
in just their home the different things
they've done to soundproof in the
different ways they get around
everything has thought put it down in
this movie and I appreciate the design
on that level also because this is the
kind of movie that has to feel lived in
and it does reason not to see it's it's
not a popcorn horror movie because we're
the filmmaker duo you wouldn't
appreciate an artistic horror trying to
communicate yeah but it is easy to maybe
be misled again like by a by a tomato
mean or scorn by people just hyping
going oh my god yeah you know you might
be expecting like a mile a minute with
the scares and the terrorizing of this
family because there's no way is the
trailer actually misleading I think what
it doesn't set you up for is
this is gonna be a very deliberate paced
movie and it's gonna be a family drama
as well but it's not like what was that
one movie that pissed off everyone with
joel edgerton oh it comes at night yeah
where you're like there's nothing yeah
yeah like the elements that you see in
the trailer for this movie they're in
this movie it's just there's a whole lot
of extra stuff in here that I don't
think audiences are really going in for
but that's what makes it such a good
film it's not like a film you know it is
like an actual it's not like a movie
yeah although it asks you to be patient
I even myself had to do some readjusting
within the first like 20 to 30 minutes
ago oh we're really gonna we really
gonna take our time I feel like
mainstream audiences could get on board
with this movie you know it's like for
me I've been kind of comparing this the
experience of Jordan Peele coming from a
comedy background and doing get out
getting amazing reviews and everyone
flocks at the theaters to go see it and
it totally lives up to it a quiet place
I could see it having a similar response
to audiences but I could also see a good
amount being like I just wasn't my cup
of tea because it was a little too slow
yeah I've heard the name like Cormac
McCarthy thrown around with this and it
is more toward that side of the spectrum
and is more like rumination but not you
know it's still compact 90 minutes and
I've never heard or it's been a long
time since I've heard an auditorium that
quiet so with if you're with the crowd
that's into it and willing to buckle
down for the Silence of it all I think
you'll have a great time if you want to
check your phone and get rowdy I think
you'll be bored if you're that [ __ ]
or [ __ ] who likes to go on her Facebook
or his snapchat during a movie this far
out from your face yeah right then
please don't go to the theaters just in
general don't go especially not this
movie yeah I feel like we know a lot of
times we do these consensus on films I
really feel consensus is pretty obvious
tars this is there's really no reason
not to see this movie I found out before
shooting this that John told me it's
pg-13 I haven't run the impression this
entire time even though I'm in the movie
it's rated R especially because there's
one specific moment where I was like
I didn't see that coming his great
violin yeah for everyone go check this
movie out it's it's just a well-made
film and it's more of a suspenseful
thriller in terms of what the horror
elements are yeah it's a horror movie
but it's not like you're gonna be
haunted at night by it all right guys
well thanks for watching you guys why
don't you tell us in the comment boxes
what was your favorite episode of the
office what do you think of Emily Blunt
is Mary Poppins boy that's relevant you
can subscribe to the reject nation and
click that notification bell so the
subscription button means something yeah
and check us out on patreon full-length
TV show reactions over there as well as
music videos q and A's whole bunch of
goodies that we offer would love to have
you become a patron eject today and yeah
ass write falls in the star dose uppers
we do use that bad boy